de prison le plan est ambitieux mais
renforce-t-il pour autant l'indépendance
des juges ce sera notre second débat
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
que contient la loi d'accélération du
nucléaire voté cette nuit au Sénat les
détails avec Marion
au départ c'est un texte technique qui
arrive au Sénat un texte qui vient fixer
et simplifier les procédures permis de
construire autorisation environnementale
nécessaire pour entamer le plus
rapidement possible les projets de
futures réacteurs EPR 2 il est important
car il permettra d'accélérer les
procédures administratives de
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
électronucléaires dans notre pays avec
deux objectifs
raccourcir les délais de réalisation de
ces projets de plusieurs années et
contribuer à en baisser le coût pour les
consommateurs mais c'est sans compter
sur les sénateurs qui estiment en
majorité que le gouvernement légifère
dans le désordre en s'attardant sur des
points techniques alors que la stratégie
même n'a pas encore été fixée on ne peut
pas débattre
sérieusement sur la question nucléaire
ça a d’avoir défini une stratégie quel
mix électrique etc etc et après on aura
des débats et peut-être des désaccords
et des divergences mais une fois qu'on
aura tranché ça la majorité sénatoriale
a donc choisi d'intégrer à ce projet de
loi l'article 1 dédié spécifiquement à
la relance du nucléaire et qui fait
sauter deux points majeurs à la
fermeture de 12 réacteurs et la
limitation à 50% de nucléaires dans le
mix électrique en 2035 nous ne
préomptons pas le débat public parce que
les 50% ils pourront devenir peut-être
75 et c'est peut-être la préférence de
ce côté-ci du de l'hémicycle mais ils
pourront peut-être devenir vain et ça
sera peut-être la possibilité ici nous
ne préomptons pas nous simplement nous
disons les 50% c'est obsolète et nous
accompagnons les mesures techniques par
une vision politique du côté du
ministère de la transition énergétique
on estime que c'est un mauvais coup
politique et que cet amendement n'a rien
à faire dans ce projet de loi technique
la stratégie tant réclamer étant prévu
pour cet été lors de l'examen au
Parlement de la loi de programmation
énergique climat
la France a-t-elle les moyens de cette
ambition nucléaire retrouvée c'est le
thème c'est la question centrale de
notre débat avec Emmanuel Galichet
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes enseignants
de chercheurs responsable pédagogique
des enseignements en sciences et
technologie nucléaire au Conservatoire
national des arts et métiers Stéphane
piano à bonsoir c'est l'air de ménéloir
et membre de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques Erwan Belize bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
au service économique du Parisien et
auteur de ce livre nucléaire une
catastrophe française livre publié aux
éditions fayards accueille également
Mathieu croissanto éditoris politique
bonsoir Mathieu et bienvenue à vous
tiens un premier tour de table peut-être
pour poser pour répondre à la question
générale c'est c'est cette nouvelle
ambition nucléaire Emmanuel Galice
je crois que oui on l'a fait sortir la
deuxième guerre mondiale tout était
détruit et on a réussi ils ont réussi à
l'époque je vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui on ne réussirait pas on a
plein de jeunes sur le territoire le la
France a beaucoup de technologie elle a
beaucoup de science beaucoup de
recherches et développement il y a
aucune raison qu'on y arrive pas donc
vous êtes optimiste je suis pas sûr que
tout le monde est aussi optimiste que
vous autour de la de la table Stéphane
piennois tiens par exemple les signes
alors il y a beaucoup de thèmes dont on
va parler dans cette dans cette émission
le parc existant
l'ambition pour un nucléaire l'avenir là
je vous pose une question sur les les
signes les EP R2 là c'est nouveau
réacteur promis par Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on sera en
capacité de les construire tenir le
calendrier ça c'est une question
centrale en l'état actuel des
compétences qui sont celles présentes
dans notre thé dans notre pays la
réponse est non c'est-à-dire que il faut
il faut une montée en puissance
extrêmement importante pour acquérir
pour qu'on ait des soudeurs pour qu'on
ait tous les corps de métiers
nécessaires pour la construction des
réacteurs maintenant c'est et quand on
dit réacteur c'est pas simplement vous
avez une cuve de susceptible de recevoir
du un combustible il y a il y a tout un
écosystème j'allais dire autour de ça et
donc ça va demander du temps ce que je
veux dire c'est que la formation de tous
ces corps de métiers va prendre
plusieurs années alors ça tombe bien
parce que de toute façon les procédures
d'instruction pour construire un
réacteur même avec les processus
simplifiés qu'on a examinés dans la loi
hier soir ça va ça va prendre aussi
quelques années plusieurs années
plusieurs années c'est 10 ans vraiment
le strict minimum on est plutôt sur des
bases de 15 ans donc on peut être
optimiste pendant ce laps de temps on va
monter en puissance pour former des
ingénieurs pour former des soudeurs que
si je vous donne ça se rejoint à
l'instant t on pourrait pas mais mais vu
le délai pour construire une nouvelle
centrale on y arrivera peut-être quoi
et on imagine il faut bien imaginer tous
les corps de métiers je disais le
soudeur on a peut-être quand on évoque
ce terme-là quand on utilise ce terme
l'image du soudeur de du bricoleur du
dimanche avec son casque et son poste à
souder dans le garage c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus technique que ça on a
besoin de bac+2 qui sont capables de
faire ça par commande numérique on est
quand même sur des installations
extrêmement sensibles et puis
effectivement on va regarder jeter un
coup d’œil dans le rétroviseur pour
comprendre pourquoi ces métiers là et
ses talents on les a un peu laissés sur
le côté perdu ou démotivé d'ailleurs
c'est aussi ça Erwan Benezet il y a la
question du calendrier la question des
budgets annoncés est-ce que c'est
tenable pour vous
il y a un petit côté méthodes quoi ou
aujourd'hui on se dit on peut vraiment
on peut y arriver on peut y arriver donc
on espère ensuite que ça a fonctionné de
temps en temps la méthode Coué ça
fonctionne enfin les 1945 donc il a
fallu 25 ans pour arriver à 1970 et donc
lancé effectivement ce ce plan nucléaire
qui s'est accéléré au moment du
gouvernement Messmer en 1974 premier
choc pétrolier et là effectivement on a
mis même pas les bouchées doubles les
bouchers tripes quadruple il faut
rappeler entre 118 et 83 les 22 premiers
réacteurs nucléaires sont sortis de de
terre et ont été mis en service en 5 ans
les 22 premiers acteurs nucléaires la
question c'est est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
serait capable de le refaire peut-être
pas tout de suite vous le dites
peut-être dans quelques temps vous voyez
tout à l'heure dans un de vos sujets
vous parliez de la justice 10000 emplois
supplémentaires en 5 ans le nucléaire
c'est 10000 emplois par an d'ici 2030
est-ce qu'on est capable aujourd'hui à
un moment où tous les secteurs sont en
tension de recruter 10000 emplois ça me
semble très compliqué voilà ce que je
veux dire en tout cas c'est que la
marche est très haute et ça pose
effectivement les les enjeux de notre
débat et on reviendra sur cette question
des des talents un peu plus tard
aujourd'hui la part du nucléaire dans
notre production d'électricité c'est
alors sauce les échos on a cherché à
l'instant T c'est 60% de la production
d'électricité en France si les centrales
tournent à plein régime on peut
atteindre les
75%. alors il y a cette question je
reviens vers vous ça va bien voir de du
renoncement de l'objectif donc qui avait
été voté à l'époque François Hollande de
ramener la part du nucléaire dans la
production écrite à 50% c'était prévu
pour
35 pourquoi pour vous c'est un préalable
essentiel c'était même prévu en 2025 par
François Hollande il a fallu une
modification de la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie en 2019 pour porter
parce que aucun au début du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron on s'est dit de toute
façon on y est à 2025 on y est ce sera
pas tenable on était encore à 75 %
d'électricité enfin de nucléaire de
notre électricité donc 2035 on s'est
bien rendu compte que les délais étaient
intenables et aujourd'hui on est plutôt
à 69% dans notre mix électrique le
nucléaire sur l'année 2022 c'est c'est
encore on va dire 70% pour arrondir donc
on voit que pour baisser à 50%, il
faudrait il faudrait des compensations
extrêmement forte extrêmement dynamique
pour compenser ça quand on a quand on
ferme par les énergies renouvelables il
faut bien comprendre quand on ferme ces
dames les deux réacteurs ça fait 1800 MW
il faut environ 2500 éoliennes en face
si on prend un facteur 2,8 pour
compenser l'intermittence de l'éolien
2500 éoliennes c'est plus d'un quart de
toutes les éoliennes qu'on a sur notre
aujourd'hui en France et pour compenser
juste la fermeture de deux ce qui est
inscrit aujourd'hui dans la PPE ce qui
est inscrit dans les documents c'est la
fermeture de 12 nouveaux réacteurs pour
baisser à 50%. donc vous multipliez par
6 ce que je viens de me raconter vous
vous mesurez à quel point la sur les EnR
là non plus on ne peut pas y arriver
immédiatement donc c'est sur du temps
long on s'inscrit plutôt sur des
horizons 2050 qui s'agisse d'ailleurs de
NR ou de développement du nucléaire et
dans cet horizon là pourquoi pas pardon
mais quand François Hollande l'a promis
les 50% en 2025 il savait ce que vous
dites les équivalences que vous nous
donnez
[Musique]
qui avait promis François Hollande en
vous me l'enlever de la bouche voilà
est-ce que c'est n'importe quoi que nous
promets Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui non
alors pour l'instant ça reste d'ailleurs
des promesses la grande différence c'est
ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui
moi je vois rien de tangible c'était le
sens aussi de participation dans la
discussion générale dans le débat hier
soir qu'est-ce concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'on a acté aujourd'hui rien du tout on
a pris des mesures de simplification
administrative hier soir dans la dans la
loi ok ça va peut-être nous faire gagner
du temps mais aujourd'hui c'est une
vision globale qui vous manque oui c'est
ce qu'a dit Daniel grimmiller rapporteur
sur ce texte c'est-à-dire attendez on
légifère totalement à l'envers ce qu'il
faut c'est d'abord se mettre d'accord
sur les objectifs Fabien gay d'ailleurs
du groupe communisme ne dit pas autre
chose il faut qu'on sache où on va sur
notre stock notre composante de
nucléaire dans notre mix électrique et
ensuite on pourra discuter de
simplification administrative on pourra
planifier mais là on marche on fait les
choses à l'envers alors Mathieu c'est
intéressant parce que donc on a fait
référence à cette
loi un peu phare du du en étant en 2005
15 depuis un vrai changement de regard
dans la classe politique sur le
nucléaire oui parce qu'on est peut-être
en train d'assister un tournant
historique même dans la classe politique
à propos du nucléaire l'image du
revirement spectaculaire effectué par le
Président de la République en quelques
mois de temps puisqu'on se souvient
quand après avoir arrêté le projet de
réacteur de 4e génération Astrid après
avoir fermé les deux réacteurs de la
centrale de Fessenheim il déclare à
présent vouloir prolonger tous les
réacteurs existants construire 6
nouveaux c'est ça et lancer les études
sur huit autres donc ça ferait 14 en
tout dans l'opinion publique aussi ce
qui est amusant c'est que les sondages
se sont inversés selon un sondage
effectué par l'Ifop pour le Journal du
Dimanche en septembre dernier et bien
les Français sont désormais très
majoritairement favorables à l'énergie
nucléaire 75% contre 25% et ils sont
aussi très majoritairement favorables à
la construction de nos réacteurs
65%, je crois un chiffre en net hausse
par rapport à un an plus tôt c'était que
51%. mais ce sondage il cachait une
autre surprise moi qui m'a qui
m'intéresser c'est que les pronucléaires
se retrouvent dans cette enquête
majoritaire y compris parmi des
sympathisants d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts puisqu'ils sont désormais à 53%
favorables à la production d'énergie
nucléaire alors là on peut vraiment
parler d'une bascule bah oui alors
attention les sympathisants ce ne sont
pas forcément les militants ni les
cadres et encore moins les élus du parti
mais tout de même quelle révolution
quand on y pense quand on se souvient
comment l'écologie politique en France
c'est construite autour de la lutte
contre contre le nucléaire avec dans la
fin des années 70 des années 80 avec des
combats très symboliques que vous avez
fait allusion à super Phénix à Chris
Malville vous souvenez des manifs des
recours et depuis ce temps le nom
nucléaire le nucléaire non merci vous
avez les autocollants qu'on voyait
partout et ben c'est devenu un
intangible pour Europe Écologie Les
Verts c'est ce qu'on appelle un totem en
politique et puis en plus pour connaître
que leur activisme leur force de
conviction avaient même fini par
contaminer si j'ose dire les autres
parties un peu aidé par l'histoire aussi
par que ce soit l'accident de Fukushima
ou la décision allemande qui avait suivi
l'excédent de Fukushima qui avait été
critiqué qui sans doute critiquable mais
tout ça avait achevé d'installer dans le
débat le fait que au fond de nucléaire
c'était fini ou en tout cas envoie
d'être fini et alors aujourd'hui voir ce
totem renversé y compris dans
l'électorat écolo c'est quand même un
séisme idéologique et politique
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en pleurant
des prix de l'énergie il y a eu la prise
de conscience que la souveraineté on en
a parlé sur ce plateau plusieurs fois
dans différents domaines mais sur
l'énergie c'était franchement
indispensable il y a eu depuis la guerre
en Ukraine notamment tout ça ça c'est
imposé dans les esprits mais il y a
aussi une autre prise de conscience
venue de l'Intérieur celle-ci je parle
du mouvement écologiste porté par des
écologistes d'un nouveau genre dans le
sillage du projet shift de Jean-Marc
Jancovici le succès de sa BD quand même
le monde sans fin vendu à plus de 600
000 exemplaires à beaucoup contribué à
populariser les thèses de ce
polytechnicien que que nous connaissons
bien attachés à l'énergie nucléaire en
tout cas au mix parce qu'il la jugent
lui ça me sa priorité c'est la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique à la
préservation du climat et jusque pour le
coup l'énergie nucléaire est plutôt ce
qu'on a de moins pire ou sinon ce qu'on
a le meilleur pour pour y préserver en
tout cas en termes d'émission des de gaz
à effet de serre et Jean gauvie ici
c'était a fait des adeptes que ce soit
dans une génération plus jeune dans des
gens qui n'ont pas forcément connu les
vieux combats des écolos et au grand
dames évidemment des Antunes nucléaires
qui n'ont rien trouvé de mieux que pour
riposter que d'aller glisser des fausses
et rata des faux zeratomes dans
certaines librairies ont certaines
librairies dans les BD de de Jean-Marc
jokovici une mesquinerie qui a quand
même qui en dit long sur le désarroi et
le déni de ces anti-nucléaires
le nucléaire décarbonés effectivement
c'est enfin voilà il est redevenu où il
est devenu indispensable et c'est
intéressant de voir comment il s'impose
aujourd'hui dans l'opinion française
mais ça gomme pas quand même un certain
nombre de questions sur la sécurité on
parlait de Fukushima sur la gestion des
déchets absolument le nucléaire a des
défauts comme toutes les énergies on a
aucune énergie aujourd'hui qui est
parfaite donc il y a des défauts il faut
qu'on ne s'améliore il faut se rappeler
quand même que l'énergie nucléaire c'est
une énergie jaune ça fait les 70 ans
moins de 100 ans en tout cas qu'on
l'utilise de manière industrielle donc
il faut qu'on s'améliore donc sur la
gestion des déchets effectivement on a
un projet aujourd'hui qui est
l'enfouissement en couche profonde à CGO
il y a peut-être d'autres
voix à explorer notamment faire une
bonne recherche et développement sur ce
sur ce point sur la sûreté nucléaire je
trouve quand même on le voit d'ailleurs
en Ukraine ça tient bien la Sûreté
Nucléaire aujourd'hui
Fukushima c'était un autre réacteur
Tchernobyl c'était encore un autre
réacteur on est sur de la Sûreté
Nucléaire extrêmement importante
aujourd'hui sur le parc français avec
des protections une défense en
profondeur extrêmement grande et il me
semble quand même que on a on a bien on
a ici correctement notre pari sur la
sûreté
une autre filière c'est à dire que
c'était un réacteur à eau bouillante et
il n'y avait pas de Dôme de protection
et ce qui fait que quand vous avez une
explosion le dos mais là justement pour
protéger l'environnement il est aussi là
pour protéger des missiles mais il est
surtout là pour protéger s'il y a un
accident à l'intérieur ah Fukushima il
n'y avait pas
Erwan
française qui alors ça peut enfin voilà
on le voit avec les problèmes de
corrosion les problèmes de talent de
personnel etc mais est-ce que ça fragile
parce que vous nous dites bon voilà le
c'est sûr et ce qui s'est passé ailleurs
ne pourra pas se passer en France grosso
modo je simplifie un peu mais est-ce que
avec l'affaiblissement des des talents
des compétences des moyens c'est
toujours vrai juste vous dites ce qui
s'est passé ailleurs c'est pas passé en
France parce qu'il s'est passé ailleurs
a quand même failli se passer en France
par exemple en 1999 au Blayais près de
Bordeaux au moment des grandes tempêtes
vous avez un amas d'algues de
différentes qui coucher les entrées de
refroidissement du réacteur et vous avez
un préfet qui a appelé le maire de
Bordeaux de l'époque un certain Monsieur
Juppé pour l'avertir que on risquait de
vider la ville parce qu'il y avait un
possible incident si ce n'est un
accident nucléaire ce que je veux dire
c'est que
on connaît ce enfin les gens qui
travaillent là-dessus connaissent cette
plus anecdote mais c'est pour dire que
en fait
la technologie nucléaire est une
formidable technologie allez absolument
fascinante de par sa puissance et sa
capacité effectivement avec assez peu de
combustible à produire beaucoup de de
d'électricité d'énergie et des carbonées
et et quand même un enjeu majeur pour la
transformation
c'est la grande raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui le nucléaire revient un peu
en force notamment y compris aussi chez
les écologistes parce qu'il y a
effectivement c'est urgence climatique à
un moment il faut faire des choix voilà
il y a pas d'énergie parfaite mais il
faut bien cela reste cela reste une
technologie extrêmement complexe qui
demande beaucoup beaucoup
d'investissements et en même temps
beaucoup de savoir-faire la question qui
est posée c'est est-ce que ça vaut le
coup aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a pas
d'autres moyens parce que on parlait des
années 70 mais les choses ont beaucoup
changé on sentait étrangleurieuse on
avait quand même beaucoup de on avait de
l'argent à mettre 200 milliards d'euros
à coûter le parc nucléaire
d'aujourd'hui est-ce que est-ce qu'avec
les nouvelles technologies et ce qui a
pas la possibilité de faire d'autres
choix tout en gardant peut-être
effectivement une part de nucléaire mais
peut-être pas à 70 c'est peut-être même
pas 50% mais ce qui a pas d'autres choix
à faire peut-être moins dangereux
peut-être moins risqué peut-être moins
coûteux et il y a notamment aussi ah bah
lesquels il y a du renouvelable il y a
le stockage ce que je veux dire les
dizaines et ben le stockage serait une
très très bonne mais les dizaines voire
les centaines de milliers parce que là
vous parlez du lit le stockage moi
j'entends le stockage des déchets donc
c'est pas ça le stockage c'est quoi
c'est pour ça je me mets à la place de
l'hôtel les spectateurs en fait le gros
problème aujourd'hui de de renouvelable
enfin un des problèmes c'est
l'intermittence donc si on réussissait à
résoudre ce problème d'interdence et
pour résoudre ce problème intermittent
il faudrait industrialiser le stockage
ce qu'on n'est pas capable de faire pour
l'instant c'est stocké mais pas
industrialisé il faudrait mettre
beaucoup de moyens et peut-être qu'une
petite partie des moyens qu'on envisage
de mettre dans le nucléaire on pourrait
le mettre par exemple dans ces questions
là et résoudre en tout cas
en partiellement le problème du
renouvelable alors moi ce que je retiens
quand même là de nos premiers débats
c'est la difficulté pour les petits
parce que les politiques qui sont aussi
liés à l'émotion
de des citoyens et des électeurs quand
il a Fukushima ça provoque une émotion
mondiale et on voit ce qui se passe
derrière et qui finalement a des
arguments pour se débarrasser du
nucléaire qui porte là aujourd'hui on
est confronté à un enjeu structurel de
décarbonation ça c'est évident et puis
un enjeu conjoncturel qui est lié à la
guerre en Ukraine comment résister quand
on est politique à la dictature de
l'émotion imaginons je ne le souhaite
pas personne ne le souhaite autour de
cette table qui est un accident
nucléaire majeur en Europe ou pire en
France vous avez raison c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que ça repose au maximum sur
la rationalité
les problèmes de Fukushima en fait les
au niveau mondial les pays qui utilisent
le nucléaire n'ont pas n'ont pas attendu
Fukushima pour s'emparer du sujet
notamment des déchets il y a eu un forum
au début des années 2000 au tout début
des années 2000 le forum génération 4
qui a dit on peut pas continuer à
produire des déchets comme ça de cette
façon là parce qu'à un moment donné on
va arriver à un stock incroyable et
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est orienté vers
des réacteurs de quatrième génération la
troisième génération c'était les EPR qui
était des réacteurs de transition et on
devait arriver à ses réacteurs de
quatrième génération qui sont des
surgénérateurs c'est à dire qu'ils
produisent autant de combustibles qu'ils
en consomment pour simplifier un petit
peu et c'était ça la voix d'Astrid vous
savez que j'ai co-produit ce rapport à
l'été 2021 c'était ça c'était un
programme de recherche qui a été arrêté
par Emmanuel Macron en 2019 et pour là
aussi pour des raisons politiques pour
faire plaisir à Nicolas Hulot pour plus
exactement pour le faire venir dans un
gouvernement et le conserver dans son
gouvernement finalement assez peu de
temps donc le jeu aurait pas la
chandelle on a on a eu ce souci sur les
déchets assez tôt évidemment si demain
matin on trouve une énergie totalement
sans déchets
non carbonés moi je signe dès demain
mais aujourd'hui je crois que la
rationalité conduit à aller vers du
nucléaire parce que on d'abord on n'a
pas entretenu notre parc suffisamment
longtemps imaginez une industrie qui a
été mise totalement à l'arrêt pendant 20
ans c'est à peu près la même chose si
vous comparez en termes d'effectif 200
000 emplois dans l'automobile je crois
que vous êtes aussi un spécialiste
automobile et du nucléaire 200000
emplois indirect ou indirect mettez à
l'arrêt l'industrie automobile pendant
20 ans et on construit zéro voiture
pendant 20 ans vous les redémarrez 20
ans après c'est une catastrophe vous
n'avez plus personne vous savez plus
faire la différence c'est que
l'automobile c'est pas un secteur
stratégique l'énergie l'électricité en
particulier
sur le nucléaire c'est effectivement de
prendre des décisions qui sont
politiques avant d'être techniques
premier erreur dans les années 70 le
dimensionnement du parc a été
surdimensionné et ce qui a fait que
aujourd'hui on attend de problèmes dans
la rénovation énergétique parce qu'on a
construit des habitats qui qui étaient
très mal isolés pourquoi on avait de
l'électricité en veux-tu en voilà et
donc peu cher et donc on ne s'occupait
pas la rénovation on était avec des
grille-pains parce qu'il fallait encore
une fois consommer l'électricité donc ça
c'est la première erreur vous avez fait
une deuxième erreur qui effectivement le
surgénérateur qui était alors c'est vrai
qu'il avait pas mal de problèmes et sur
12 années de de fonctionnement il a
produit environ trois années de
d'électricité 40 ans voilà mais mais
donc et on prend une décision politique
alors que peut-être effectivement
c'était un laboratoire et qu'il
convenait de continuer à travailler
là-dessus et ensuite il y a en 2018
quitte là encore est une décision
politique et non pas technique je ne
sais pas si Fessenheim devait être
arrêté ou continuer si elle était en
état ou pas je pense que c'est
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui doit
le dire mais ça n'est pas l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaires qui a pris les
décisions et ça c'est une erreur
fondamentale alors la sécurité ça pose
aussi la question des métiers des
savoirs indispensables dont on parle
depuis le début de ce débat pour
relancer cette filière nucléaire vous
avez fait référence à l'intervention de
votre collègue de sénateur communiste
Fabien gay hier soir en séance on prend
cet extrait justement sur les talents
et on n'a pas été les seuls à le dire
elle se fera si on attire des talents et
si on permet aux hommes et aux femmes
qui vont construire la filière nucléaire
de le faire dans les meilleures
conditions pour leur sécurité et pour
notre sécurité
c'est ça la réalité et le père de
Flamanville je le redis c'est pas la
question
administrative qu'à 1000 retard c'est on
a cassé les métiers et d'ailleurs ce que
vous êtes en train de faire ce que vous
en félicitez l'Université des métiers
c'est pas ce qui a été
autrefois l'école de DF qu'on a cassé
des libéralement à la fin des années 90
et donc il faut retrouver ça
il faut retrouver ça il faut le mettre
au cœur du débat public
parce que il y a pas de filière
industriel et il n'y a pas de
savoir-faire sans hommes et femmes
qualifiés
un organisme qui a été créé il y a 5 ans
qui s'appelle le gifen qui regroupe la
filière nucléaire c'est ça qu'est-ce qui
a été fait qu'est-ce qui est fait pour
rendre de nouveau ces métiers techniques
attractifs alors il y a deux choses qui
ont été faites il y a déjà eu un édec
donc un quelque chose un traité qu'on a
qui a été signé avec l'État donc avec le
ministère du travail de manière à faire
un état des lieux de toutes les
formations et de toutes les besoins en
compétences ensuite la filière s'est
organisée autour d'un programme qui
s'appelle match pour essayer de voir un
petit peu tous les besoins qu'ils
avaient et comment avec la
sous-traitance aussi et aujourd'hui il y
a un vrai enjeu de compétences le
sénateur l'a dit absolument parfaitement
c'est les pouvoirs publics qui doivent
le faire l'éducation nationale en
priorité l'enseignement supérieur
également il y a énormément de jeunes
aujourd'hui je suis en france je suis
allée chercher les chiffres de
l'éducation nationale il y a 12 millions
d'écoliers de collégiens et de lycéens
en France je veux dire on a besoin entre
10 et 15000 salariés pour refaire le
parc par an pendant plus de 10 ans mais
c'est pas les mêmes métiers au début
qu'on aura après sur l'exploitation au
début on va avoir besoin de génie
civilis on va avoir besoin de mécanicien
de d'électricien puis au fur et à mesure
il y a du nucléaire qui va arriver donc
avec des compétences un peu plus
techniques mais
il y a de moins en moins de bacs qui
sont consacrés à ces films
technologique technologique de seulement
qui mène à l'industrie ça veut dire 4%
seulement des jeunes aujourd'hui vont
dans l'industrie tout le reste c'est du
service et alors les bacs pro c'est
encore pire parce que vous en avez une
centaine dès qu'il y a un petit besoin
industriel
mais l'éducation nationale là aussi
voilà un paquebot difficile à bouger
donc ça la Russie dans je sais bien
qu'on est dans le tournant quand on
parle du nucléaire mais ça va pas enfin
moi j'ai du mal à croire qu'on puisse
recruter entre 10 et 15000 personnes par
an pour renforcer la filière ça me
semble un peu
utopique alors utopique non je ne crois
pas il faut vraiment donner envie donc
ça veut dire que l'attractivité va être
le point central des prochaines années
et surtout aussi sur les filles alors
les filles là pour le coup vous êtes
aussi bien dans les bagues dans tous les
bacs à peu près 10 % à aller jusqu'à
dans les électriciens il y a 1% de
filles donc les filles il faut qu'elles
viennent faire la science elle faut
qu'elle fasse de la technique il faut
que les métiers techniques soient remis
à l'honneur et il faut qu'il y ait une
vraie attractivité aussi bien par
rapport au pouvoir public que à
l'industrie
une bonne rémunération bien sûr
le problème c'est leur donner un statut
particulier peut-être dans le dans le
nucléaire l'attractivité elle existe les
salaires sont élevés absolument vous
parliez des soudeurs donc ça
effectivement des soudeurs et des
compétences extrêmement précises avec
donc des salaires qui sont là donc
l'attractivité elle est elle existe elle
est là et pourtant ça ne suffit pas
d'abord aujourd'hui on est dans un
contexte où il y a quasiment non plus un
seul secteur actuellement qui ne soit
pas en tension donc le nucléaire va être
en tout cas avec d'autres concurrence
avec d'autres et en plus elle arrive non
pas et qu'à handicap d'attractivité mais
peut-être à handicap d'image depuis
quelques années mais d'attractivité non
donc elle arrive là pour le coup sur le
marché avec il faudra encore offrir
autre chose et quoi on ne sait pas ça va
être ça va être compliqué il faut
montrer aux jeunes que aujourd'hui
l'argent ne fait pas tout que le pouvoir
intellectuel le savoir
autrement on y arrivera pas vous avez
peut-être des enfants moi j'ai des
enfants j'essaye de leur montrer que
l'industrie est quand même une voie
professionnelle intéressante alors il y
a une des choses qu'on a envie
effectivement de transmettre aux enfants
en tout cas si on parle de ces secteurs
qu'on a dont on aura envie de leur
parler c'est c'est l'image c'est l'image
qui est donnée et aujourd'hui sur le
nucléaire genre j'en reviens
régulièrement pour moi on est en train
de déjà de de réfléchir sur le nucléaire
futur sans avoir résolu et vous l'avez
un petit peu abordé les problèmes du
nucléaire présent et tant qu'on aura
réélu résolu complètement les problèmes
du nucléaire présent peut-on vraiment
déjà parler du nucléaire du futur et de
proposer à nos enfants effectivement de
leur donner envie d'aller travailler
là-dedans et les deux problèmes
principaux c'est un on en a un petit peu
parlé le stockage et passer de fois s'il
stockage électricité le stockage des
déchets et puis deux le démantèlement
nous n'avons encore absolument pas a été
au bout d'une d'un démantèlement d'un
réacteur nucléaire aujourd'hui en France
alors que on arrive aujourd'hui la
moyenne d'âge des réacteurs c'est de 37
ans ils étaient conçus pour aller
jusqu'à 40 donc on est à 3 ans de la fin
de leur et on a toujours pas des mots
clés et on ne sait plus quoi faire des
déchets nucléaires au point que on est
obligé d'en envoyer quelques-uns en
Russie c'est cette question de de de
l'âge de nos centrales tiens je redonne
un chiffre sur le nombre de centrales ou
de réacteur à l'arrêt aujourd'hui en
France 56 réacteurs nucléaires en France
dont 13 sont à l'arrêt c'est c'était
bien pire il y a quelques semaines et
c'est ce qui va sans doute nous
permettent de avec aussi les
températures qui étaient 12 jusqu'à
présent de de passer un hiver sans
coupure en tout cas on peut on peut
l'espérer Stéphane viennois il faut
alors sur cette question de la durée de
vie de nos centrales je vous dites les
sénateurs la majorité à au Sénat il faut
abolir la liste des 12 fermetures de
réacteurs pourquoi et est-ce qu'on peut
indéfiniment enfin en tout cas combien
de temps on peut prolonger la durée de
vie de ces centrales alors on parlait
d'erreurs tout à l'heure je vais revenir
sur cette légende urbaine des 40 ans
avec qui a décrété un jour que une
réacteur nucléaire avait une durée de
vie de 40 ans un espèce de obsolescence
programmée avant l'heure ça n'existe pas
les termes exactes des ingénieurs qui à
l'époque ont construit des réacteurs
c'est dit avec ça on est tranquille pour
au moins 40 ans et ça y est à partir de
là on a on a fait une une doxa politique
idéologique en disant ça c'est sûr à 40
ans alors tomber dessus et on va leur
dire que les réacteurs sont à mettre à
la casse il faut il faut raison garder
comme tout outil industriel ça vieillit
il y a de la maintenance certains au
bout de 40 ans peuvent être au bout du
rouleau si je puis dire et d'autres
peuvent être prolongées jusqu'à 80 ans
aux États-Unis c'est la même technologie
c'est des réacteurs à eau pressuriser de
la même façon il y a aucune raison pour
que ce soit pas le cas et en plus on a
des des autorités indépendantes en
France qui sont extrêmement rigoureuses
je dis parfois sévère et on a choisi de
d'avoir une tête bicéphale avec l'ASN et
l'IRSN donc il y a des contrôles qui
sont extrêmement pointus extrêmement
exigeants en France il faut faire
confiance à la SN à un moment donné vous
avez raison c'est pas aux politiques de
dire si on a si on est en capacité de
conduire à de prolonger un réacteur
c'est la SN qui a l'autorité donc voilà
sur le retraitement vous avez
parfaitement raison il y a juste deux
réacteurs pour lesquels on a été très
vite non pas sur le démantèlement mais
sur le retrait des matières des
combustibles
radioactifs c'est fait ça name on était
très très vite pour retirer le
combustible de Fessenheim on se demande
pourquoi c'est c'est vraiment la volonté
de dire on va pas pouvoir aller faire
marche arrière parce qu'on sait qu'une
fois qu'on a retiré le combustible c'est
très dur de progrès de réactiver donc là
aussi vous dites que c'était politique
oui bien sûr on a voulu prendre la aller
très vite prendre de tout le monde de
cours pour dire oui on prend des
décisions puis là c'est définitif elle
fait celle-là on y reviendra pas c'est
dommage quoi et on n'a pas de sinon ce
serait peut-être en train de relancer
fait cela absolument je pense que oui
sans risque
alors justement
mais bon vous connaissez bien la
question ça me semblait très très
compliqué même sans avoir retiré j'étais
aux côtés d'alovergeon donc l'ancienne
patronne d'Areva dans une émission sur
BFM qui est le
affirmait qu'on aurait pu qu'on pourrait
encore relancer Fessenheim bon après
elle est un petit peu revenue elle est
un petit peu modéré son ses propos mais
à partir du moment où il y a une ça
aurait été extrêmement complexe mais
d'un point de vue administratif
réglementaire et encore plus technique
de relancer Fessenheim c'est un peu
comme une vieille maison il vaut mieux
faire table rase et reconstruire là pour
Fessenheim puis à la rigueur aujourd'hui
le le débat n'a même plus grand intérêt
sur l'histoire des 40 ans c'était dans
les mémoires de Marcel Boiteux l'ancien
le patron d'EDF à l'époque qui qui avait
donné comme instruction assez assez
troupes assez ingénieurs de construire
des réacteurs avec l'objectif d'une
durée de vie de 40 ans
alors effectivement aujourd'hui aux
États-Unis on prolonge à 60 peut-être à
80 il y a des éléments vous en parlerez
certainement mieux que moi des éléments
qu'on ne peut pas remplacer notamment la
cuve du réacteur on ne peut pas les
remplacer à le vieilli cette cuve et
elle subit des des fissures et on avance
quand même on n'a pas on n'a pas le
l'expérience pour savoir comment un
réacteur de 60 ans peut réagir Emmanuel
dichet sur cette question sur les 56
réacteurs nucléaires français
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on sait de leur
durée de vie potentielle est-ce qu'on
peut tous les prolonger jusqu'à 50 60 80
ans parce qu'il faut faire du cas par
quatre quoi c'est c'est là aussi faisons
pas de politique quoi absolument il faut
faire du cas par cas vous avez raison
c'est l'autorité de sûreté qui a tout
l'attitude pour dire si un réacteur doit
être arrêté ou pas aujourd'hui sur le
parc l'Autorité de sûreté a dit que tout
allait bien les les les 56 sont en bonne
sont de bonne qualité encore
ensuite effectivement la cuve tout est
absolument regarder
surveiller avec avec des avec vraiment
des détecteurs dans les cuves etc donc
on n'a pas de d'énormes problématiques
aujourd'hui sur les cuves en fait sans
aller jusqu'à le risque d'incident voire
d'accident il y a un problème auquel on
est tous confrontés par exemple quand on
a une voiture il y a un moment elle
commence à avoir beaucoup de kilomètres
et on se dit qu'est-ce que je fais ce
que je la garde encore et je vais avoir
de plus en plus de de maintenance dessus
enfin de travaux chez le garagiste ou
est-ce que là allez hop je je je la
vends et j'en achète une autre là on
sait on en est déjà au deuxième problème
générique on avait eu un en 2017 sur les
générateurs de vapeur et pardon le
deuxième là vous allez parler de la
corrosion sous contrainte qui est pas un
général
parce qu'on va jusqu'à maintenant on va
se perdre
mais ou alors même sans aller jusqu'au
problème générique on sait où parliez
des 69% et c'est effectivement
la part de production d'électricité en
2022 cette part auront on reviendra
jamais au-dessus de 70 % parce que les
les réactions
il y aura toujours des problèmes
maintenant pour être au-delà des 77
et avec ce risque de problèmes
génériques qui met quand même là pour le
coup l'approvisionnement électricité en
danger surtout
un petit détail en fait il y a le grand
carénage qui est en ce moment entre 2022
et qui va qui va durer encore deux trois
ans même quatre ans les grands travaux
qui permettent justement d'augmenter la
durée de vie et ça effectivement ça
oblige les réacteurs à s'arrêter plus
longtemps et donc ça nous permet pas
d'avoir les 70 % ou voire un peu plus de
d'énergie nucléaire mais lorsque c'est
ce grand carénage donc c'est grands
travaux seront terminés donc
remplacement de gros composants etc donc
là on avait on a fait un gros gros
contrôle technique on a remis aux normes
de sûreté comme les EPR finalement les
les réacteurs de Génération 2 vont
devenir au même nombre de sûreté que les
réacteurs de génération 3 je vous
entends mais je me mets à la place de
noter les spectateurs qui pour l'instant
n'ont pas entendu un mot dans ce débat
je pense que si peut-être que l'un de
vous la prononcer mais ces mots flamants
ville parce que quand on parle de la
sûreté nucléaire de voilà de de des
talents et des qualités et de la
capacité de la France à produire du
nucléaire bah forcément on se dit que ce
fiasco vous donne des arguments à ceux
qui sont antis nucléaires écoutez ce
qu’en disait Yannick rouslestan ancien
salarié de naval Group qui travaillait à
Flamanville alors il est devenu militant
Greenpeace Marion Vigreux l'avait
rencontré pour son documentaire les
défis de la relance c'était il y a un an
écoutez
ces cailloux ont été projetés sur les
réacteurs d'à côté l'ASM d'autorité sur
tes nucléaire immédiatement avec les
travaux et en fait après ça c'est
enchaîné toujours dès qu'on a coulé du
béton il y avait des problèmes avec
véritablement des trous dans le béton
qui était juste la coulée béton était
raté après on a eu des problèmes sur le
tunnelier qui a servi pour faire le
tuyau d'évacuation des rejets où il
s'est cassé les dents sur l'ancienne
mine de fer qui se trouve là on a des
problèmes de corrosion sur le liner à
cette enceinte métallique il est à
l'intérieur des problèmes de soudure à
répétition en permanence jusqu'à
maintenant puisque au moment où on se
parle encore plusieurs dizaines de
soudures sont à refaire ont finalement
on a une situation qui est extrêmement
dégradée alors que le réacteur n'a même
pas encore fonctionné et je rappelle que
ces moyens c'était tibia un an Stéphane
piennois il y a une question que je vais
vous poser est-ce que c'est pour cette
année c'est c'est ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'on se demande réacteur à
finir par Démarrer et puis surtout
est-ce que c'est pas révélateur de voilà
notre incapacité aujourd'hui à produire
de nouveaux réacteurs fiables ces
révélateur de la question que vous posez
tout à l'heure la perte de compétences
en fait moi j'ai été frappé on m'a
expliqué dès le début de mon de mon
mandat de parlementaire que Flamanville
c'est effectivement un échec industriel
il y a aucun doute là-dessus j'ai pas de
personne je peux dire le contraire
aujourd'hui parce que le design de ce de
ce réacteur est extrêmement compliqué on
a on a laissé faire une entente
franco-allemande sur ce réacteur là
alors qu'on avait on savait faire les
choses nous-mêmes on a accepté de
travailler bon c'est un c'est devenu un
échec industriel il y a aucun souci et
puis ensuite parce que pendant 20 ans ce
que je disais tout à l'heure on a non
seulement arrêté de construire mais on a
fait du bashing sur le nucléaire comment
voulez-vous que des étudiants se
dirigent au-delà de la terminale se
dirige vers des études
où ils entendent pour lesquels ils
entendent la longueur de journée à
longueur de journaux télévisées ou
presque
il faut pas aller c'est ça et moi on m'a
expliqué qu'on avait plus de soudeur en
France et c'est pour ça c'est la raison
pour laquelle aujourd'hui on a fait
appel à des soudeurs italiens des
soudeurs américains j'ai rien contre ces
nations ce chantier sur le changement
bien sûr et c'est parce qu'on a perdu la
compétence qu'on a on arrive à une
absurdité à une catastrophe nucléaire
mais pas dans le sens où vous l'entendez
peut-être exactement c'est que on avait
le savoir-faire et on sait laisser
piétiner on a laissé un avantage
concurrentiel être totalement laissée à
l'abandon alors qu'on était on était
leader sur le marché
Erwan il est bon ce chantier c'est un
fiascon est d'accord il est mal née
c'est à dire que c'est de sa conception
même ce que vous nous dites que que
naissent ensuite les les problèmes
récurrents année après année deux choses
vous parlez de bashing est-ce que c'est
du bashing quand on quand on pose les
questions les questions ont été posées
il y a des réponses qui n'ont pas été
apportées donc c'est là où moi je suis
pas sûr qu'il du bashing pour répondre
il a été très mal vendu il a été vendu
sur un mensonge et ça même même des f en
l'admet en offre c'est que 3,3 milliards
d'euros comme coût du réacteur tout le
monde savait que c'était intenable et la
date de livraison aussi et donc j'allais
y venir mais je rappelais juste
aujourd'hui on en est la Cour des
comptes à 20 milliards d'euros donc
c'est pas les 12 qu'on vend de temps en
temps c'est 20 milliards d'euros et la
date mise en service 2012 on est en 2023
et a priori ça serait 2024 puis je vous
fais même à Paris ça sera pas 2024
pourquoi parce que en fait l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire a demandé à ce que le
dôme soit remplacé alors j'ai plus la
date mais peut-être en 2024 ou 2025 mais
va-t-on mettre en production un réacteur
qu'on va être obligé d'arrêter quelques
mois plus tard aujourd'hui on en parle
pas pour remplacer le dôme nucléaire je
pense que non et donc je ne suis même
pas certain que Flamanville sera en 2024
donc je réponds à votre question ce qui
a été mal conçu bah déjà on s'était on
partait d'un d'un deal politique avec
les Allemands et non pas d'un choix
technique qui serait le plus pertinent
donc c'est quand même encore une fois un
problème et oui il a été sans doute mal
conçu et mal présenté mal vendu et
Emmanuel gallichet les réacteurs EPR 2
que Emmanuel Macron veut lancer faire
construire on n'est pas sur le même
modèle c'est quoi c'est pas tout à fait
le même modèle effectivement il sera
beaucoup plus
alors ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'avec
le père
de la faute des Allemands non non c'est
pas la faute des Allemands les Français
aussi je veux dire au niveau de la
construction le génie civil c'était
quand même pas si vous n'avez pas de
bons plans c'est compliqué effectivement
comme le monsieur dit il y a sûrement eu
des problématiques aussi de béton etc ça
il y a pas de souci les soudeurs qu'on a
plus aujourd'hui les il y a
effectivement 7000 soudeurs qui qui
manquent mais dans l'industrie générale
c'est-à-dire c'est pas que le nucléaire
le le soudage effectivement n'est plus
un métier intéressant
et ensuite ils ont ils ont là où sur
l'EPR vous aviez je sais pas 100 Vannes
et bien ils vont ils vont en mettre que
10 d'accord ils ont un catalogue ils ont
réduit les catalogues extrêmement
fortement de manière à ce que on puisse
aller plus vite que les sous-traitants
sachent exactement les portes les portes
il y avait presque sur le perde
Flamanville c'est une boutade on le dit
souvent mais il y a une porte à chaque
fois qu'un il y a une entrée et c'est
une porte différente quoi
chercher Fayard merci encore